Bitte schön.
Hallo Guten Tag.
Ja, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bilal Alptan. Ich bin hier auf diese Station als Diensthabender Arzt tätig.
Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Jawohl.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Herbert Schönling.
Herr Berth, schön. Könnten Sie sich denn vornamen Nachname Buchstabe?
Vorname ist Herbert, also Heinrich, Emil, Richard, Bertha, Emil, Richard, Theodor.
Nachname ist Schönling, Siegfried, Caesar, Heinrich, Ö, wo mit Umlaut.
Nordpol, Ludwig, Ida, Nordpol, Gustav.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 24 Jahre alt.
Was ist Ihr genau geworden?
Ich bin ab dem 3. März 1999 geworden.
Noch eine Arbeiterin?
Am 4. März 1999 geworden, also im letzten Jahrtausend.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß.
Und wie groß, wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 75 kg leicht.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Student.
Ich studiere Informatik.
Informatik.
Herr Schönling, was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Schönling?
Ich bin ein Fahrrad unterwegs gewesen.
Ich bin mit dem Fahrrad ausgerutscht.
Und auf meinen rechten Handgelenk gefallen.
Und auf meinem Kopf gefallen.
Auf rechten Handgelenk und das Haupte.
Wie ist das passiert?
Könnten Sie den Unfallhergang genau beschreiben?
Ich bin Fahrrad gefahren.
Und wollte die Kurve nach rechts nehmen.
Und dabei war der Boden zu schmutzig.
Und dann war es der Boden.
Und ich wollte die Kurve nach rechts nehmen.
Und dabei war der Boden sandig.
Und dabei ist mein Fahrrad ausgerutscht.
Ich habe die Kontrolle verloren.
Und bin auf das rechte Handgelenk gefallen.
Und auf meinem Kopf.
Haben Sie momentan Schmerzen?
Ja, in meinem rechten Handgelenk.
Und im Kopf?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe einen Helm gehabt.
Sie haben mich geschwollt.
Sie sind, ist Ihre Hand geschwollt?
Ja, mein Handgelenk ist geschwollt.
Wo genau ist geschwollt?
Im Bereich meines Momentes.
Ich habe eine Speiche.
Speiche?
Wo bin ich?
Ja, im Handgelenk vielleicht.
Es war eine Ellen-Seite, sondern an der Speichenseite.
Ja, Speichenseite?
Ellen-Seite und Speichen.
Ja.
Speichenseite ist geschwollt.
Im Bereich wo der Daumen ist.
Noch einmal, bitte.
Wo mein Daumen ist, in dem Bereich.
Ja.
Auf dem Bereich des Radius.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie,
griebeln oder taubheißen Gefühle?
Haben Sie taubheißen Gefühle?
Wo meinen Sie?
Am rechten Hand.
Am rechten Hand?
In der rechten Hand habe ich keine Taubheißgefühle.
Ich habe auch keine gut Gefühle.
Mussten Sie erbrechen, Herr Schamlin?
Ich muss nicht erbrechen, aber ich habe auch nicht erbrochen.
Ich habe nicht erbrochen.
Okay.
Erbrochen.
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Übelkeit? Nein.
Mir ist es nicht übel.
Okay.
Herr Schöning, leiden Sie an eine chronische Erkrankung?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente?
Medikamente nehme ich nicht ein, nein.
Nach dem Unfall, haben Sie etwas eingenommen?
Nein, ich bin unmittelbar hierher gekommen.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, am Blinddamm wurde ich operiert.
Da war ich 10 Jahre alt.
10 Jahre alt?
Und das war es?
Also Operation?
Ja, also Operation war es, ich hatte sonst keine Operation gehabt.
Okay.
Herr Schöning,
gibt es chronische Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
In meiner Familie, was meint ihr mit chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine z.B. Zugverkrankung, Bluthochdruck,
erhöhte Blutverzweite.
Also, ich weiß, mein Vater hat Bluthochdruckerkrankung.
Meine Mutter hat Schildrüsenunterfunktion.
Okay.
Leben, ihr erzählen noch?
Ja, die leben beide.
Gott sei Dank, wer soll mein Studium finanzieren?
Studium kostet Geld.
Mein Eltern finanzieren mein Studium.
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ich habe zwei Schwester, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich weiß nichts von Erkrankungen, das ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Jetzt, ich möchte zu Ihrer generellen Situation etwas fragen.
Spölen Sie sich fibrisch manchmal, oder haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe kein Fieber.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Eigentlich gut.
Können Sie gut schlafen nachts?
Ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie keine Medikamente nehmen.
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie eine Allergie haben.
Meine Eltern haben mir gesagt, dass ich keine Penicillin nehmen darf.
Wie reagieren Sie sich auf die Penicillin?
Mit Schwellung im Hals und Atem-Mode.
Laut meinen Eltern.
Kann ich mich nicht mehr so erinnern, da war ich ein Kind, wo ich das hatte.
Noch Unverträglichkeiten gegen Lebensmittel?
Nein, gegen die Klopfernak, wenn ich die einnehme, dann hat es Magenschmerzen.
Die vertrage ich nicht.
Ich nehme nicht regelmäßig den Klopfernak, aber wo ich sie genommen habe, hatte ich Probleme.
Wenn Sie Schmerzen haben, nehmen Sie die Klopfernak.
Wenn man die Klopfernak nicht hat, dann habe ich mal die Klopfernak eingenommen.
Das war nicht gut für mich.
Sind Sie geimpft gegen Kindheit, Krankheit und Corona?
Ja, Corona bin ich nicht geimpft.
Ich war erkrankt, habe mich geimpft und die Kinderimpfungen haben meine Eltern alles gemacht.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihre Gewöhnheit.
Lauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viel Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Sieht man das mir an?
Sieht man das bei mir an?
Dass ich rauche, weil ihr das wissen sie, dass ich rauche, dass sie fragen.
Ich habe nicht genau verstanden.
Das war ein Witz.
Okay, fragen Sie weiter.
Wie viel Zigaretten rauchen Sie täglich?
Ich würde sagen, so eine halbe Päckchen, ich rauche schon einen Tag.
Seit wann rauchen Sie halbe Päckchen?
Seit drei Jahren ungefähr.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Oh, nee, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Früher habe ich mal getrunken, das habe ich nicht vertragen, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Nicht vertragen.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine.
Ich nehme Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Droge?
Oh, nee, ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie das geschrieben wird.
Ja, Herr Schoenig, meinerseits habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, ich würde sagen, wie geht es weiter, Herr Doktor?
Was habe ich denn? Was denken Sie?
Was wird mit mir jetzt gemacht, was passiert mit mir?
Herr Schoenig, zuerst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und dann ein Röntgen von Ihrer Hand, Ihrer rechten Hand veranlassen.
Und gegebenenfalls möchte ich auch ein CT vom ERCOPF veranlassen.
Und dann können wir sobald wir die Ergebnisse erhalten, können wir ausführlich sprechen.
CT vom ERCOPF?
Ja, ich meine das vom ERCOPF.
Weil in der Unfälle kann man sich im Kopf verletzen
und vor sich halber möchte ich Ihrer CT anlassen.
Okay, ist das schädlich?
Ja, ich komme zur Tomografie.
Wir werden mithilfe der Röntgenstrahlung durchgeführt.
Es ist ganz schmerzfrei und eigentlich nicht gefährlich,
weil Röntgenstrahlung sehr gering beim Computer Tomografie ist.
Und wenn manchmal Patienten brauchen oder manchmal um die Bilder besser zu sehen,
werden wir Kontrastmittel im Zugang in Wänen geben.
Aber wenn Sie eine Allergie gegen Kontrastmittel haben, können wir alternative Diagnose verfahren und veranlassen.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Herr Schülpert, wann war Ihre letzte Tetanus im Punkt?
Die haben vor sechs Jahren ungefähr.
Vorsicht, vielen Dank.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Was ist 1 bis 10?
0 bis 10.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ich weiß nicht, was 1 oder 10 ist.
Die Schulnoten in der Türkei sind eine 10 sehr gut.
In Deutschland ist eine Schulnote eine 1 sehr gut.
Bei 0 haben Sie keine Schmerzen.
Bei 10 haben Sie unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Wenn ich meinen Handgelenk rückstelle, habe ich ungefähr 5 Bewegungen.
Bei Bewegungen habe ich 9.
5 von 10 in Ruhe und 9 von 10 bei Bewegung.
Haben Sie öffentliche Wunder oder Blutung?
Nein, ich habe keine Wunden an der Haut, sei es am Kopf, sei es an meiner Hand.
Keine Hautverletzung.
Haben Sie Hautverfärbung im rechten Handgelenk oder im Arm?
Hautverfärbung?
Wie Fleck, zum Beispiel, Blutverfärbung?
Blau oder rot?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Könnten Sie Ihr Hand bewegen?
Ja, ich kann nicht.
Ein Handgelenk kann ich nicht gut bewegen, es tut weh, dabei habe ich Schmerzen.
Aber meine Finger kann ich bewegen.
Wie ist Ihr Hand auch ein bisschen belästig?
Ihr rechter Hand?
Nein, ich würde nicht sagen.
Das ist normal.
Haben Sie Hautabschürfungen oder irgendetwas?
Nein, nicht am Kopf oder woanders, oder an mein Hand.
Wenn Sie Ihr Handgelenk bewegen, hören Sie eine Knarze, eine Geräusche?
Ich glaube, so viel kann ich nicht bewegen, das tut mir weh.
Oder haben Sie diese Geräusche gehört?
Gehört, das war so schnell alles.
Ich bin aufgestanden und habe Schmerzen gehabt.
Wenn Sie uns erst anfangen, bitte.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarz.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient auf den Notfallaufnahmen aufgenommen.
Ich möchte ihn vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz seid?
Ja, deswegen bin ich hier.
Herr Herbert Schöning, der 25-jährige Patient,
hat sich bei uns wegen eines Fahrradunfalls vorgestellt.
Ich habe beim Fahrradfahren ihr Kontroll verloren und gestürzt.
Er ist auf der rechten Hand und auf der Kopfseite gestürzt.
Er hat beim Fahrradfahren Kopfhölm getragen.
Er hat keine Beschwerden antropft, aber am rechten Handgelenk
wurde er geschwollen.
Er hat keine Erbrochen und hatte keine Übelkeit.
Vor Erkrankungen gab es nur eine Appendectomie mit Zähnen.
An der Familienanamnese fanden sich Brückhochdruck,
Arteelehypertonie,
An der Familienanamnese ist unaufwählich.
Der Patient nimmt keine Medikamente.
Er raucht seit 3 Jahren halbe Päckchen.
Alkoholkonsum liegt nicht vor und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Der Patient leidet an Penicillinallergie, die mit Halsschwellen und Atomen, die Anaphylaxie,
und der Patient nimmt die Medikamente, aber kann nicht gut vertragen.
Er hat eine Magenschmerz.
Er ist gegen Kindheitserkrankungen geimpft.
Er hat gegen Corona nicht geimpft, aber genießen.
Er hat eine Tethanusimpfung vor 6 Jahren gemacht.
Er hat eine Parise oder Durchfutungsstörung, oder das habe ich nicht rausgehört.
Er hat nach Tauchheitsgefühl und Krebeln gefragt, aber die Frage wurde verneint.
Er hat eine Lebenserscheinung von Parise.
Er hat zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Er hat auf das Handgeland gefallen und auf den Kopf geplaten.
Er hat keine Beschwerden.
Er hat eine Atmnesie.
Er hat eine Stationärkontrolle.
Er hat keine Atmnesie.